[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after all enough enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
oh good morning monthly I got a yeah
clean yourself I gotta clean myself up
because our next guest is uh it's um
it's like looking into the Sun she's
great nowhere near as attractive my life
this is a horrible way to start because
my wife or my next guest I love my wife
as yourself into a corner this means
she's she's a very fetching woman and
she's really made some waves here of
course online and a lot of you know her
from all sorts of different platforms
you can follow her now on the youtubes
have no idea if she is monetized if she
is soon to not be as all of us all of us
are you just on the show lash Megan
Kelly seniorita Kelly thank you for
being here appreciate it hi my pleasure
thanks for having me I don't know if I
would say my pleasure I know we're
talking a little bit off air here but um
you're very you're a very friendly
person is that is it that's real right
that's what's real people think I'm like
this Raging [ __ ] because you know they
see me doing a cable news primetime show
talking to politicians and that's not
like a rosy walk in the park right my
normal personality is totally charming
yes it is if I had to do that I would be
swallowing a knife at the end of every
episode they'd be like hey we're coming
back with the great American and
Stephens dead what happened
is so fast Isis you're talking about
torture you're talking about you know
like shootings it's like and people
think you're gonna just be like all
roses and unicorns it's like okay so
that but that doesn't mean that I'm not
a happy kind person it's just not an
appropriate really the meter for
prime-time cable news well I asked us
because obviously I've we've had
interactions before because we both
worked at other networks and and you
were always pleasant when I would see
you in print like the cameras would stop
rolling okay that was fun
whereas I had had other people who the
cameras stopped rolling your nose like
get the hell out of here kid so I you
know I just want to make sure that there
isn't a slow burn you see all the news
coming out now about Ellen right it's
like all these stories about how she's
doing asked to be on scenes or wasn't
nice to guess or she wasn't hurt her
crew or whatever and I feel like I'm
exactly the opposite people say that I
like this sort of Ice Queen but you'll
never find any crew member I work with
who would ever say that
about me like I treat the people I work
with really well yeah but people think
I've heard that term ice queen a lot
just because it's like well you know you
Tiger politicians what are you gonna do
like most of them tend to be jerks and a
lot of them tend to be liars and it's
like what are you gonna do like I'm not
gonna buddy up to those guys they're not
my friends
no you're hanging out with the worst
people among humanity they're the modern
day Pharisees and Sadducees they
crucified Jesus is how we want to
introduce this so I want to I want to
move on to you had this exclusive
interview with with with Tara Reid not I
won't have to be clear people yeah the
Joe the Joe Biden Terry yes a lady
allegedly I think that covers me I'm not
a journalist see Megan but allegedly
right I have to cover my bases a
potential sniffing so I want to roll a
clip for people who haven't seen this
yet and then ask you a couple of
questions about it because it was it was
fascinating and I'm curious as to I mean
obviously this is an exclusive it's a
huge scoop a huge story right now let's
see a clip for people who watched him
when he went inside the skirt he was
talking to me at the same time and he
was leaning into me and I pulled this
way away from his head I remember and so
he was kissing my neck area and he
whispered did I want to go somewhere
else
in a low voice but he said something
vulgar and I asked what he he said I
want to do and he said it low and I was
pushing away and then he pulled back
immediately when he could see I wasn't
complying I was obviously just tensed up
and frozen and not kissing him back and
I'm not going with him and he pulled
back and he looked at me and he said
come on man I I heard you liked me now I
want to be clear again it's allegedly in
Joe Biden his claim that he doesn't
remember having lunch so we don't know
what's what right now how did you get in
exclude this come about because obvious
is a huge story and you had this this
scoop did she just feel like you were
going to be fair minded I mean like I
later found out that she's been trying
to reach me for a couple of weeks and
had asked
number of journalists who had reached
out to her to have a contact megyn kelly
and surprisingly was told no never heard
of her I don't have any way of reaching
her it's a competitive industry yeah
they send some homing pigeons and that's
that's what happened yeah like I know
the names that she reached out to and
they do have yeah
anyway after like a month watching
people ignore this story it's just such
[ __ ] because you cannot believe Tara
Reid I have no stake in whether people
believe her don't believe her but the
coverage of her story versus the Trump
accusers versus Christie Blasi board who
accused Kavanaugh I mean like the
difference is just so glaring you're
starting to get kind of irritated by the
the double standard and now I just saw
like she was getting beaten up pretty
badly in the press so I decided to just
call her just to see like how are you
handling medicine are you okay just
human-to-human sure not really one of
you I know I perfectly have a sick on my
couch here in Montana with my kids right
I was gonna say you don't have to work a
day in your life I don't know if that's
if I'm revealing the folks but you're
obviously well off you don't need to do
this no I don't need to but like I'm
also like you know ladies out there you
can appreciate like I gained the corona
you know the cove in 19 my runes are
like five inches long
my face is unspooling like a like a bad
sweater from no Botox I wasn't dying to
get off the couch and go for the camera
yeah but I felt for her because she she
seemed to really look like on her heels
you know she seemed really overwhelmed
like her bankruptcy had been posted and
her her daughter who's 25 her picture
and home address had just been posted
the New York Times inadvertently posted
her social security number this is a
woman who had to change your social
security how does that happen how does
the New York Times evidently Doc's a
social security number it's not like
they left one portion of her address
there and someone you know like with he
will not divide a Shia LeBeouf they
tracked the smoke signals like you just
you just released your social security
number they in their defense it was like
a picture of an ID card that had like
they took a picture that haven't have
yet is social security number on it I'm
sorry they can't be bothered to check an
ID card for personal information
Tara Reid has no money this woman has no
money she she just got this lawyer Doug
Reid or who helps a lot of sexual
harassment victims
I think he's helping her pro bono and
she just got a PR person who I think is
in a similar book she has no money for
anything anyway so I called it and she
said you know I've been trying to reach
you I love I'd love for you to talk to
me and I was like you know Tara I I was
involved in a me-too situation but I
wouldn't go easy on you and I have a lot
of tough questions for you like I I
myself have questions about her story
and she's like I wouldn't expect
anything less so I play my left Montana
for the first time in a couple of months
and I flew out to California we did it
well I have so many things that I want
to get you first off you are correct the
first thing I was noticing was your
roots I was ignoring the rest that you
know some people might there might be
firm debate over whether you know you're
a nine point nine or a ten I don't know
if that sex is with those roots just
ruin it for me a woman that women are so
much more harsh on women there's not a
man the world washes right now Benny
Hart right yes myself trust me
I know I think like well that's just
because you need to love yourself more
and in my case it's it's inaccurate like
I thought that I asked for a mirror that
makes me look slimmer and I punched the
mirror when I found out it was just a
normal mirror so um let me ask you this
though about Tara Reid before we move
into her specifics and by the way please
do tell me if I ask any specifics
because I'm not a lawyer what I can ask
what I can on that front but as someone
who's obviously been in the media and
you've you've covered this this type of
story with a me-too movement for a long
time and I think you've been pretty fair
minded about it and like you just said
you've been a victim of it yourself how
do you balance presenting what you
believe is plausible versus sort of what
had become a Twitter trend because there
are two camps believe all women always
and then people who believe in due
process and unfortunately if sometimes
you believe somebody and another instant
you don't people think that
you're on the other team no I I think
that's the Lonnie you you pick who you
believe like you you listen you use your
brain you use your common sense same as
a juror would in a courtroom
and you'll figure out who you believe if
you don't and that's the way it should
be
right the oh we should be doing as
journalists and people who control the
process is making sure it's fair I said
from the beginning he's women like
Alyssa Milano with the believe all women
you know t-shirt on at Christine Blasi
Ford
that's absurd I don't get a resumption
of truth-telling because I have ovaries
like women have an inability to lie
because the women since when well so but
to be clear to be medically accurate
over easily ovaries do produce a trace
amount of sodium pentathol so I do want
to be clear be medically accurate here
yeah I think that's but that's a tough
position to take as a woman especially
like you said who's been in the middle
of that how hard is that it's not a
tough position to take if you're not
looking for love from the whoa crowd
right which I'm not I don't need their
love and I don't have it roots yeah well
I just I feel like at heart I am a
lawyer I I was a litigator for ten years
and I covered the Duke Lacrosse case
that was one of my first big stories and
that woman there was lying
she was lying and if you paid attention
to the facts of that case as opposed to
just going with the whoa line of the
woman must be telling the truth the
three privileged white guys at Duke must
be lying she was a person of color and
they were white she was a person of
lower socioeconomic status they were
privileged they were Duke she was a
stripper it was like I had all the
ingredients that made the media root for
her not for them yeah and if you just
put it with an open mind and didn't root
for anybody but facts you wound up in
the right place and my general feeling
is that most stories that that's the
case well I think it's the key for
people like you but this you are an
anomaly in a sense that like you just
the rest of the media basically
crucified these people in the court of
public opinion
it took a while for that to come out
like mattress girl UVA right a lot of
these high profile cases that guy at
Columbia was mattress girl frugal don't
remember he doesn't get graduation back
and I know that you've covered it fairly
um I just
why that is an exception thank you
seriously to this day people think that
she's some sort of feminist hero right
and you know that do you know the facts
I mean see and I'll tell you on the
Kelly file I put on a couple of cases
there was there was in terms of what's
happening on college campuses right now
a young man and thank God is being
rectified but Betsy DeVos Place oh sorry
I think you did under President Obama
was wrong it was a planner College is
saying these are the standards you must
impose you have to impose them but
you're gonna lose all federal funding
but like it's up to you right but of
course they did it and guys who get
accused on college campuses they can't
cross-examine up until now can't crosses
down have no right to discovery can't
even be in the room of their lawyer and
if they lose they're expelled and
labeled a sex offender and I'll just
give me one example I have one guy Mike
his lawyer came on my show cos he was
remaining anonymous
he was accused by a woman who said it
was raid he said it was consensual he
got expelled they said you didn't
because they always say he did it right
the standards so low for conviction for
guys so they kicked him out of college
he's kicked out and then the roommate of
his alleged victim came forward and said
I feel really bad but I had these text
messages from her that really helped him
and his lawyer was like let's see and
the text messages were like from from
the alleged victim I know angel I'm not
innocent I had him come over oh we did
it and then moments after her alleged
rape what did she do she invited another
guy over and slept with him none of
which he knew he could have raised any
of it in this tribunal so they went back
to the school and said this is such a
bull right you got to let him back in
you gotta get rid of this label a sex
offender and they wouldn't do it right
so my point is simply it's so unfair to
just choose a side and say women always
tell the truth and guys are the liars
and the perpetrators it isn't always
true it isn't and so you have to go to
these situations with they'll come on oh
and I do appreciate you keeping the
source anonymous when describing Mike my
wife and I are elaborate role-playing
let me it's very busy some reason legal
turmoil kit so I think that answers the
question why Tara Reid went to you
because of Tara Reid went to you know
let's say Gloria Allred people
okay all right well we got it an
immediately would be questioned and then
of course people who would question it
would be accused of being sexist in your
case I think she said okay I need to go
someone who has been calling balls and
strikes I wanted to ask you this because
you mentioned Christine Blasi Ford we
got a lot of flack because nothing
really matched up you say this is
different the difference is night and
day
what do you see is the primary
differences because some people will say
well you're just politicking at this
point between Ford and Reid if there are
them what I say with what I say is 90
days the way the media is approaching
two stories right like they put
Christine glossy board on the cover of
Time magazine as a heroine Tara Reid
couldn't get anybody to even put her on
television after months of trying to
come out with this story right when I
was at NBC my limited stint at NBC not
only did they put Julie sweat Nick that
liar in my opinion in the brick having a
case I'm not everyone else's - but yes
great I saw people allegations but they
were on a reports they put on a report
on NBC um it had two links up here it
was like at least two or three links of
hearsay one anonymous person said to
another anonymous person who spoke to
NBC that brick have enough like 20 years
ago might have pushed a woman up against
a wall somehow somebody figured out who
the who the person was who started this
chain link and tracked down the alleged
girlfriend you threw against the wall
who's now a federal judge she was like
never happened what is this right but he
ran with the story right they ran with
that story with anonymous to anonymous
like Tom Reed bubkis has she been on NBC
no she has not so it's like to me just
the media never stand if it doubles and
the double standard of the women who
were like these feminist Crusaders when
it was red Cavanaugh on her on the hot
seat and now we're like there's plenty
of reasons to disbelieve Terry that's
fine maybe but there were plenty of
reasons to disbelieve glossy porn you
just chosen not to because was a
different guy who's being accused well I
think the primary difference and then I
would like to get your take because you
sat down with her the primary difference
is not that there are reasons to
disbelieve thar read and Christine Blasi
fort there are no reasons
as far as verifiable evidence to believe
Christine Blasi Ford story every time
she came out and said this happened
someone came in said well no we actually
can't corroborate that and quite a bit
could be proven the opposite and also
right now when you have Christine sir
not Christine buzzing for when you have
read saying well I think you should
search through Leafs these files and
they're being sealed and Joe Biden says
I won't release them whereas Cavanaugh
came in with his journal that could be
corroborated with he it was generally
accurate and of course that's not 100%
but what grown-ass man keeps a journal I
was just thinkin shake today the windows
were dirty taken check I'm exaggerating
to make a point but we get to the point
where they're asking Brett Kavanaugh if
he drinks beer on Tuesdays and we're not
covering read at all and by the way
there's no footage of Cavanaugh sniffing
children repeatedly well I mean the
thing is with Blasi four people found it
so persuasive that she told the
therapist about it all these years later
it's like well you know what Christy
Tara Reid has a very credible
professional woman who is at Ted
Kennedy's office when they met who she
told about contemporaneously with the
alleged event and that woman says thar
has been telling the same story for 27
years she's got another woman who she
told the story to two years later who
was a Democrat who's going to vote for
Joe Biden who says tar has been telling
the same story for 27 years now
does that mean the story is true it
doesn't I don't maybe fara lied to these
people some women make stuff up I mean
you know not everybody is perfectly
together
right um so I'm not opining on that but
in terms of supporting evidence
she's definitely got more witnesses than
Bazzi for it ever did right and it also
matters when you're talking about motive
because she was talking about it back
then where she had really nothing to
gain other than speaking the truth with
friends and not saying that's why
Christine before he came forward but you
know okay so so there's a couple
possibilities I mean there is a
possibility with the respect ATAR and
she knows I'm not trying to diagnose her
on television or on podcasting but
there's a possibility that Tara there's
something wrong with Tara right and sure
she needed attention or she just she
made up the story
she was ticked off at mine who knows
like women do sometimes make things up
for whatever reason that is possible the
other possibility is like she wanted to
get it
like she was getting pushed out of the
office she's pissed off I'm gonna get
Joe Biden okay mr. so let's let's see
that one through so she makes up the
story she plants the seed with the
corroborating witness back in 1993 okay
she's got the witness on board she's got
the story straight why didn't she ever
drop the hammer
all this time Joe Biden he ran for
president about 200 times he got on the
ticket with Barack Obama as the as the
vice president never nothing and then
even in this race when he first started
running and the Democratic field was
fast
nothing nothing so like if she's been
lying in wait for the guy for three
decades she stinks at her killing
operations right like she's a long time
and wait yeah um you know lady wait a
long time so yeah I don't know if that
one makes sense oh I think that the
thing that would make sense more is if
she's lying the thumb wrong way right
yes and there is also the possibility
that something happened that isn't as
severe as she's saying now in other
words she could have been listing a
complaint because he just you know
snifter rubbed her shoulders or said
nice breasts like he said with other
women which you know on the record or
can I get a minute alone with her for a
minute which listen I don't know that's
not rape I need to be clear but I do
have women and who work in this office
and if I were to say can I have a minute
alone with you for a minute and sniff
for example two cute Maddy
you would all kick my ass promptly it
would be like a pig pen just a pile of
dust so it's to me that's bad enough and
and maybe that's what happened with Lou
Terry can you say the sexual harassment
something she say find a complaint and
there was recently a news report about
it the fact that her now ex-husband he
had said in a filing in 1996 my wife was
sexually harassed in the office of Joe
Biden but there is a distinction between
harassment and assault I think she's got
she's got plenty of documentation that
she accused him of harassment time which
will be cheaper but that's different
from the salt
she's now cleaning but she her two
corroborating witnesses the two best one
she has they say she told them about the
alleged assault the penetration the
whole thing right from the time it
happened
with the one woman's case and two years
later in the other woman's case where D
since you're closer to this obviously
net where do you think this goes what do
you think the next step is do you think
he's going to have to unseal where no no
no because who drives the story the
media right there's your interest in
this there I think they're checking a
box like I'll give them the benefit of
doubt and say they've got genuine doubts
about Tara Reid and they don't want to
go too far out on the limb right in case
she turns out not to be a truth teller
but whatever the motivation is it dies
left it without media interest and and
the only other way it would stay alive I
think is if other women with similarly
like severe allegations came forward but
why isn't that enough went you know for
example when you look at Aziz Ansari
where what effectively amounted to a bad
date right we're not talking about some
that wasn't consensual I and I think
it's creepy or even if you look at louis
c.k creepy it's an abuse of power but
he's not Bill Cosby I do think that it's
important that's where I agree with Matt
Damon we don't lump them into the same
category that being said when you
compare Aziz Ansari to sniffing underage
people to making people uncomfortable
and inappropriate touching and invading
space after being told about it
isn't that enough with Joe Biden to it
it would seem like the media would say
it's a different standard is what is
what I don't think the sort of the seven
women who came forward with the sniffing
and the touching of the neck you know
those reports a year ago April at 19
thats not gonna be enough you know he
effectively handled that with the tweet
that was like you know I'm sort of a
politician I'm handsy I get it that was
yesteryear all I'm over it
they're not he kind of got a pass on
that yeah and I think part of it is is
you look at the other guy right Trump's
been accused way over 12 women of far
worse than just a little touching of the
neck and so people are kind of like I'm
not gonna make a federal case of Joe
Biden's rubbing somebody's hair sexual
assault like Tara Reid's alleging is a
different story but on the other hand
you know Trump's been accused of that
too so people are like yeah there's an
election they're stuck between a rock
and a hard place I think a lot of people
people who aren't consistent hear you on
this and I I do think it comes down to
burden
proof and certainly when it relates to
Tara Reid I think it's more comparable
to let's say Christine Blasi Ford as a
non-lawyer it seems like there's a lot
more to go on and there's different
treatment of that I don't know if you've
been following recently you know we ran
into this I'm not a journalist and
unfortunately unfortunately is a
commentary in the state of modern
journalism I've broken some stories that
you would think these folks wanted
remember the lady who drank the fish
tank cleaner chloroquine and that donal
thing yeah so we we actually had some
exclusivity
yes the husband so I will actually since
I want to get your opinion on that but
we actually had the exclusive documents
that we released on this show so we
didn't have that wasn't exclusive but
was available to the public but hadn't
been reported was that she was a
longtime Democratic donor right and that
she actually this we had an exclusive
social media posts of her saying I can't
believe you would believe Trump what an
idiot she hated Donald Trump and then
what we had the exclusive to was there
was a john deere court case i think
where she sued john deere and using some
information that file we found one where
she was charged with domestic abuse
against her husband and we had exclusive
documents that we revealed that was big
yeah i have a brilliant researcher we
call him reg and it's crazy that we were
able to find this we released it and no
one covered on the left and then I
called the reporter who broke it at NBC
and I said listen you reported a story
where she drank fish tank cleaner with
her husband her husband died and you
guys must have known that she was a
democratic donor you said she drank it
because of Donald Trump she said well I
don't I don't know that I said well did
you look at her political donation
records up the first thing did you look
at her criminal record because she also
hated a husband so I'm saying she hated
Donald Trump and she hated her husband
he died she didn't do you think that
changes she goes well I think you have a
message that you want to push and you
should go with that
I said no doesn't that change the story
if she said she drank it because Trump
told her to and she clearly hates Trump
and now we know the husband was a civil
engineer let's drink some koi pond
cleaner no one caught it how does that
happen and I you're an exclusive
position as someone who's been a
journalist and now is doing on your own
how does that happen how does no one
check that so you know exactly how right
there's a there's a bias against the
information you think she wouldn't have
reported it if it had been the opposite
way around if the woman had been Pro
Trump
and Biden had said the controversial
thing that she'd done you know it's like
we talked about this a couple months ago
when NBC though all the stuff came out
with Ronan Farrow right about them like
why they spiked the with Nancy story and
in their defense was it just didn't meet
the journalistic standards we have it
was just just couldn't get it over the
line even though they had Rose McGowan
on the record saying Harvey Reiter NBC
had her on the record saying that
doesn't meet our journalistic standards
like what but anonymous to anonymous
with the principal girlfriend saying it
didn't happen that was enough to put the
allegations on about against Brett Kevin
right why because of bias that's why
yeah but how can people trust so I think
a lot of people blame President Trump
for the distrust and the media but this
has been going on for so long now do you
think it's accelerated recently or do
you think it's been the case for a long
I think honestly like the old-school
objective trustworthy journalism is dead
that's what I think and it was it wasn't
a murder by President Trump it was more
like an assistant to herself he was like
the Kevorkian but they're the ones who
defend ourselves he said we've abandon
all objectivity I mean it's gone and
Trump exposed it he exposed a better
than England he helps and his rhetoric
about enemy of people whatever that's
too much but they the ones who weren't
what he said they weren't like CNN
became what he said yes CNN use
objective I used to watch CNN every
night when I got ready for the Kelly
file because it was like okay objective
news I can get the straight skinny
Hubbell on and I'll do my thing no more
and and they're worse than MSNBC because
they're parading out there masquerading
as objective news people at least MSNBC
owns it and says this is who we are
that's our deadline yeah I ain't seeing
it like the Apple and I don't even know
what the hell they're saying anymore but
they're not objective and now just a
picture of Chris Cuomo's biceps with sin
thaw injected into them yeah that's a
good analogy
he's like the Kevorkian you just strap
takasi to a chair and said I'm gonna
leave this file here beer it don't do
anything I wouldn't do
and you know you walk back in and you
can draw your own conclusions yeah we
we've had this I was I had a rude
awakening
no go ahead go ahead your words are more
important than my why like why did CNN
have to do it right like I have a lot of
friends over there who I really like and
respect but I feel like the decision
came from the top that they were gonna
get Trump that they were part of the
resistance media and maybe that their
objective approach wasn't working
financially but to me like that's been a
real loss in journalism because I from
me longer have a place I can go where I
believe I'm just gonna get facts and not
spin it so I just read the news now I
don't I don't really do a lot on
television yeah well I think what you
have to do is assume there's spin and so
for me I just read spin so I have I set
up my own favorites my bookmarks and if
I read fox news I read MSNBC right
afterward if I read anything at Daily
Caller
I read slate right afterward I want to
make sure that I know exactly what both
sides are saying CNN is almost a perfect
at that point there's no value because
they don't tell you the lies by omission
and in my experience I I'm glad that you
have friends that you know respect I
have nobody I know and respect over
there but I can say that about myself
but here's the thing that upsets me more
yep okay it doesn't work and it like sit
there a dying medium okay that would be
enough but now when you look at I mean
we've had lawsuits with NBC ABC Viacom
MTV Comcast so many just for these false
copyright claims we had it for streaming
the Oscars when we didn't even show the
Oscars was in a little window you know
in this hat you don't get those live
viewers back now and of course Vox
obviously as part of a conglomerate now
they're actually trying to silence
people who are trying to deliver facts
online and independent outlets and my
question what is that like for you
because you're one of the few people
who's been doing this and in both a big
media company and now by yourself how
would you say your experience is is
different and what concerns you most
well I mean the one thing I don't want
to do in whatever I do next night I
haven't figured that out yet I'm kind of
enjoying myself at the moment but I
I'll get back out there in some capacity
is I don't want to work for some
corporate over the way you know I don't
want to be told how to cover the news or
feel like I must cover it in a certain
way and and I can see sort of as more
people pop up with power you know online
digitally whatever they're threatened
right like yeah it's if you get a big
exclusive at Joe Rogan does if then
Shapiro does they don't pick that up
from that on television even though you
have a video feed you can make a very
easily steel clip and run it so why
don't it's because they don't want to
promote you right because you're the
you're a big threat to what they have
and they can sort of see the future yeah
um but I will say to me it feels like
two different worlds like I feel like
there's a different audience watching
cable then there is getting their news
online and I on like the news online the
digital ayah seems younger than the
cable news audience yeah right they
shouldn't read because one can easily
feed the other but I don't think they
understand this medium and I think it's
only recently that they're even taking
it seriously that that is a problem
obviously because now they're a little
bit late to the party and unfortunately
they have far more dollars and so
they're trying to change the landscape I
think I think something that that's
changed in and if I'm not mistaken maybe
Anthony Kamiya talked about this I don't
know that it's original is we always had
to deal with the FCC right it was a bit
of a game cat-and-mouse like oh you can
say oh that guys that I don't know if
you could say that guys are dead but you
can't use it scatological II and we knew
the rules and you try and dance up to
the line but we knew who we were
engaging with now we thought there would
be no gatekeepers online right would be
there there would be no censors
unfortunately there's become a louder
and even more strict voice and that's
the voice of the mob the censorship
doesn't come from the FCC it comes from
the people who want to ruin someone's
livelihood and then they exert pressure
for example let's say with YouTube to
change their policy based on what is
determined to be offensive is that a
change that that you force saw coming I
know I didn't I thought this was going
to be the Wild West for a lot longer
mm-hmm I guess not and I always thought
that sort of the loud sort of thumb
warrioress
President Obama I thought was right on
that was something Sparky said about it
he's like that's not activism you would
get that mr. Collins for somebody to be
canceling I thought that they would be
sort of putting the right
for what they are you know I mean just
like small people who really don't have
enough to worry about really just want
to tear down others who don't have the
same opinions as they do on
controversial issues you know like
you're you're in the business of
discussing controversial issues that's
the business I have been in as well it's
not like it's not like being David
Schwimmer and Jennifer Jennifer Aniston
you know like yeah well we take on tough
tough topics it's going to result in
some people feeling ruffled if we have
advertisers cut and run every time that
happens they're not gonna have anything
left to advertise on you know so yeah I
do think the description
you know options are gonna become bigger
I like what Dave Rubin is doing where
it's like you sort of go and just do
your own thing you know have to worry
about the advertisers yeah but it's
tough for the consumers because they
don't want to pay for every single
personality that they like that's true
and that is what we do you know we have
a licensing agreement with blaze and mug
club and so people get Ruben and they
get our show and what we do is we always
make sure that we're providing more free
content than ever as opposed to pulling
it away and I see that a lot with with
well we've talked about CNN but a lot of
networks where they put up a teaser and
it doesn't work right people don't want
to engage with their content any people
don't want to engage with corporations
they want to engage with people not
something they want to have a personal
connection to the people that they watch
and they don't want to have one pulled
over on them they don't want to go to a
second it's a 20-second teaser I got to
go to CNN but if you respect the medium
and you say you know what I'm gonna
provide something here that is YouTube's
appropriate that has a beginning middle
and end in context and if you want to
support what we're doing we have a
subscription service
I think that's changed a little bit
because early on the only thing that
worked with subscription services and
they thought that would work continually
was pornography and then no subscription
service services worked but now you have
a generation of people who kind of are
used to paying on the patreon generation
we didn't really have that so it's
amazing how quickly it's changing and
don't think it's lost on me that you
were kind enough to put us in the same
category I don't believe that you ever
dressed up as a woman and interviewed
Wendy Davis ending her career that's
what I do I need to show up ooh yeah
it's preferable but it's most important
is that you make sure it's directly in
the center of the video so that it is
picked as the thumbnail otherwise you
know if it's
if a boob is revealed in a forest I
don't know it's funny actually I use
that quote that you made one time we
killer bees with my wife I wouldn't have
that's sexist we don't tolerate that on
this program yeah let me ask you this um
and again if ever cuz listen I know how
these things work and we've all worked
with companies we have NDA's and you're
doing your own thing so just tell me
piss off you can't by the way Oh piss
off YouTube we're gonna go exclusive to
muck lip you got a free half-hour
there's gonna be another half hour